[Música]
aníkin ya estamos acá los tres estaban
más nerviosos que yo que venir acá a
hablarles a todos ustedes
todos desde niños cuando somos niños
somos criados de una manera única
especial en mi caso yo fui criado por un
jardín cuando tenía como 4 años de edad
mis papás se separaron y nos bajamos a
la casa de la abuela en la casa de la
abuela junto a la casa de la abuela
había un terreno un terreno en el cual
había un huerto antiguo
al poco tiempo que nos mudamos allí mi
hermano y yo a gusto mi hermano tiene
habilidades diferentes y dos años mayor
que yo decidimos entrar y explorar ese
espacio y entramos por un portón y
varias encontramos un lugar muy mágico
un lugar que se convertiría en nuestro
refugio
ahí jugamos hoy
bueno ahí tuvimos distintas experiencias
algo que yo entré y vi esa selva y una
selva y la selva como que me dijo tú
eres tarzán yo ahí mi hermano agarra un
palito y era gran narrador de partidos
de fútbol la agarraba y sería tanto
cachito ramírez se la pasa estar cosas
que son jugadores en mi época pongo un
gol yo me dirigí lava hasta las hormigas
ganan a todos los campeonatos me tiran
los goles de todas las maneras
hasta que él se cansaba y me sacaba
tarjeta roja
y ésta de ahí ha ido me a todos los
leones de mi reino pero ellos también me
tomaron a mí que eran mis perros me
acuerdo también que aprendí a jugar las
escondidas mi mamá me buscaba para hacer
las tareas escolares y nunca me
encontraba porque tenía una guarida
secreta ahí que compartía con una ratita
la ratita nunca delató mi presencia el
niño la suya ahí también
me acuerdo que me regalaron una honda yo
todo el tiempo estaba así que le
apuntaba a los pajaritos signo del
ganado que tenía pésima puntería y
repente pum le doy a uno cae se muere y
me da una pena horrible y entiendo
entierro al pajarito y también le
entierra la onda
al final del día siempre su vida mi
árbol que era un níspero que era mi
árbol preferido porque porque me da de
comer pero aparte tenía una rama linda
es donde me arrodillaba y ahí podía ver
todo mi reino un lugar que yo cuidaba
porque porque este lugar a mí me siempre
me da cariño me da seguridad y me daba
libertad libertad para ser yo mismo
nunca me dijo que tenía que hacer ni
quién tenía que ser en ese lugar era
siempre yo me nutrí a mi esencia con mi
hermano
años después por una coyuntura familiar
este jardín es destruido y se pone una
losa de cemento ahí y sin saberlo el
espíritu de ese espacio pasa a vivir en
mí y con él las alguna sabiduría la
sabiduría que somos uno con el mundo que
lo que hacemos a las demás personas y le
hacemos a la naturaleza nos lo hacemos a
nosotros mismos
pasar un tiempo comenzó a viajar por el
perú y descubrir toda una cultura que
también las niñas y niños eran criados
por la madre tierra y crear la cultura
aquellos con sus como visión
andino-amazónica ahí era costumbre o es
costumbre que los niños a cierta edad
les dan una oveja para que ellos críen
la abeja pero que la ovejita también le
escribía a ellos o le daban surcos de
tierra con unas plantas para que ellos
también críen ahí la tierra pero que las
tierras y las plantas también los
escriben a ellos
o un montón de niños igual que mi
hermano y yo siendo criados por la madre
tierra después fui a la universidad
después unos años y ahí me enteré que el
mundo no estaba bien que estaba haciendo
degradados los ecosistemas que me
estaban siendo agradar a dos por los
estilos de vida nuestros hábitos de
consumo también me enteré que la
tecnología y dinero solos no resolverían
los problemas porque la tecnología y
dinero no son ni buenas ni malas depende
del uso que elegimos y el uso que le
damos depende nuestros valores y
actitudes por la vida y eso resulta que
se desarrollan de manera puntual hasta
los 12 años de edad en la niñez y ahí
descubrí que la mejor manera es que las
niñas y niños estén en contacto regular
y positivo con la naturaleza y cuiden de
ella entonces al enterarme de esto dije
ya pues ya está solucionado el mundo
deben estar criando a las niñas y niños
con la naturaleza en todos lados porque
eso que dices crea empatía en ellos pero
no no estaba sucediendo eso para nada
diría que lo contrario
está antes hubo una migración de lo
rural a lo urbano
ahora está viendo una migración de lo
real a lo virtual
y es así tanto que hay unas estadísticas
como en eeuu que dicen que niños que
están conectados con una pantalla más o
menos entre 8 y 18 horas
perdón niños entre 8 y 18 años están
conectados a una pantalla o un monitor
más de 53 horas a la semana
y tanto es así el tema que ya hay un
término definido que se llama trastorno
por falta de naturaleza que da ciertos
indicadores de cómo las niñas y niños
que están tan desconectados en su
personalidad que tienen más ansiedad más
hiperactividad menos empatía más
zapatilla más desconfianza y son
características que vemos en la sociedad
en general y que hacen que no sea que
sea muy difícil que podamos avanzar
hacia un mundo sostenible fue entonces
que digo bueno voy a crear una fórmula o
hacer algo al respecto y creo esta
fórmula que dice desarrollo sostenible
igual a múltiples variables que pueden
ser cualquier cosa o según muchas cosas
más que las niñas y niños cada vez estén
mejor más que la naturaleza esté cada
vez mejor porque si no no es
sostenibilidad pero hay un tercer factor
que es que las niñas y niños crezcan en
contacto regular y positivo con la
naturaleza porque la naturaleza tiene la
capacidad de crear en ellos empatía y
compasión es decir un buen corazón jamás
vamos a reemplazar lo que una un árbol
hace sentir una niña un niño cuando lo
trepan o jamás vamos a reemplazar lo que
es un caballo les hacen sentir cuando se
acercan o cuando se revuelcan ahí con su
perro en el pasto y están ahí que juegan
una tecnología en inteligencia y
sabiduría nuestra va a reemplazar esto
entonces que voy a llevar eso a la
práctica y para eso creé una
organización en el año 95 que se llama
aña asociación para la niñez y su
ambiente and ya tiene como misión
emparentar a las niñas niños y jóvenes
con la naturaleza y empoderarlos como
agentes de cambio para que sean desde
para que de sus hogares escuelas y
comunidades puedan adoptar y promover
estilos de vida sostenibles y con la
organización nace a este personaje nace
año y con ella nace un cuento una
historia que se llama el gran tesoro de
la naturaleza en ese cuento
en ese cuento ella con su hermano quien
que está ahí y una serie de otros
personajes
y hacen qué
promueven inspiran a las niñas y niños
para que les autor o en un espacio de
tierra donde ellos puedan ahí hermanarse
con el aire el agua la tierra las
plantas los animales y puedan hacer
cosas que sean buenas para ellos las
demás personas y la naturaleza y entre
todos los personajes le llaman latín y
la tierra de niñas niños y jóvenes está
pasa a ser una metodología en la vida
real que consiste en que los adultos se
entregan un espacio de tierra ya sean
los hogares escuelas o comunidades a sus
hijos oa las niñas y niños en general
donde ahí puedan desde desde medio metro
cuadrado de tierra o una maceta donde
entren 3 plantas o más espacio de tierra
puedan ahí criar la vida y la
biodiversidad quedan cosas buenos para
que sean buenas para ellos las demás
personas y la naturaleza un lugar de
estante ellos puedan plasmar su visión
de un mundo mejor y construirlo un lugar
donde ellos se sepan y entiendan
profundamente que tienen la capacidad de
transformar su entorno desde temprana
edad entonces desarrollamos todo una
metodología con anne y kings que son los
caracteres principales los que promueven
esto de manera protagónica
estas son instituciones educativas
empezamos con instituciones educativas
esta es una de ellas donde está vacía si
tenemos a la tierra no subordinada a
nuestras intereses en el mundo
occidental y con la metodología
desarrollan una visión de cómo va a
quedar el lugar crean un logotipo y le
ponen su nombre y ahí el guardia estaba
transformado y este lugar servía como no
solamente para proveer de contención
emocional a las niñas y niños como
sucedió a mí con era chiquito en mi
jardín sino también pasó a ser un
recurso pedagógico para los docentes
donde podían enseñar a las niñas y niños
con un propósito donde las ciencias
matemáticas lenguajes no son un fin sino
son un medio para formarlos como agentes
de cambio y al apra y como práctica en
la práctica y con cariño sintiendo y
tocando
esta experiencia se fue multiplicando en
distintos instituciones educativas y
pasó acá y una otra que es solamente
había cemento es además instituciones
educativas con sólo cemento entonces ahí
sacaron 5 metros cuadrados willy para
haber sacado estos 5 metros cuadrados
boca y fue muy difícil porque hay reglas
para construir pero no hay reglas para
des construir y en un mundo insostenible
que tenemos que dar marcha atrás y girar
hacia un mundo sostenible tenemos que
poder desconstruir entonces no habían
reglas para sacar cemento pero bueno lo
hicimos una empresa constructora
paradójicamente sacó el cemento lo
rompió y las niñas y niños y por el muro
de berlín hicieron su colita y con su
martillo ahí sé que cada uno cedió su
piecita y yo pudieron a través de la
práctica experimental que estaban
transformando su entorno una niña me
dijo ay joaquín como que se hubiera
sacado la segmento de mi corazón el
cemento de todo este lugar y el amor
podía volver a fluir
y ese lugar que son seis metros
cuadrados atiende a 250 alumnos y ese es
como como la maestra que está ahí la
maestra madre tierra ese es otro lugar
en la montaña igual no lo transformaron
como van a ver ahí hay diversidad y
alegría y color hay todos los tipos de
formas porque esas son las cosas del
lenguaje de las niñas y niños por ahí
ellos aprenden con cuando aprenden
cuando hay emoción si no hay emoción en
uno aprenden y esto contrasta bastante
con el clásico biohuerto escolar que es
bien adulto céntrico bien el señor a
dinero al fondo que es el que les dice
qué cosa tienen que hacer no es bien
mecánico y no es emocional y es muchas
veces solamente el tema productivo de
chiquitos no y no les dejan ni un pedazo
de en el espacio que están ahí
trabajando no dejan ningún espacio para
la propia naturaleza para que brindes
para que éste para que brinde sus
servicios ecosistémicos y para que las
niñas y niños aprendan de los silvestres
lo natural porque en la naturaleza está
en nuestra propia naturaleza y si no la
podemos encontrar ahí entonces dónde
y hay paso hogar es una niña que le dan
seis metros cuadrados frente a su casa y
miren cómo lo transformó con la ayuda de
su abuelo y de su mamá y ahora ya creció
con su tierra en niños y vaya que su
corazón también está igual ese es un
niño en las montañas también dividido su
tierrita sus 25 metros cuadrados en
zonas para él para su familia y para la
naturaleza y dice sí también obvió
soportando no sintiéndose protagonista
generando un cambio en el mundo y la
metodología en hogares ha ido
multiplicando en costa sierra selva y en
distintos estratos socio-económicos y en
zonas urbanas y rurales pero no se quedó
ahí y siguió en barrios y ese es un
barrio en típico barrio en una zona
marginal donde hay un montón de
pandillaje y las niños niños querían un
lugar propio entonces pidieron a la
junta original un espacio iba y se lo
dieron y acá está la transformación que
lograron un lugar donde pueden aprender
emprender y jugar y desde donde son
protagonistas de donde precisa se saben
aprenden haciendo que pueden transformar
sus vidas y pueden transformar el mundo
esta es una comunidad donde los
comuneros les entregan 20 hectáreas de
bosque das fijo
porque más fácil de mantener te deja
hacer las trochas no chequear los
árboles etcétera pero no era tan difícil
y ahí ellos se empoderan con la
metodología crean su nombre le ponen su
cartel de entrada y hacen unas reglas
que era no cazar no talar no quemar no
echar basura que eran todas las cosas
que antes los adultos hacían en ese
bosque y claro no había ningún animal
pero ocho meses después pusimos una
cámara trampa y miren lo que apareció
apareció un ocelote que es un tigrillo y
un jaguar un dique es un puma pequeño y
mucho más animales y las niñas y niños
mucho más comprometidos con su espacio y
ahí no se quedó en comunidades pues
también se fue iglesias dijimos hemos
hecho una alianza con 44 capillas que
están transformando el entorno donde
están las capillas que probablemente en
zonas urbanas son los pocos espacios de
naturaleza donde hay y no están siendo
bien utilizados y los están
transformando desarrollan su visión con
las niñas y niños y ya están en el
proceso de transformarlos como espacios
donde las niñas pueden aprender jugar y
emprender
al famoso empresas también hay un famoso
restaurant astrid y gastón frente al
mismo también ahí creó un espacio donde
donde van los clientes los hijos de los
clientes donde van los hijos los
colaboradores y también los vecinos por
ahí también los frecuentan los niños
frecuentes y hay un gobierno local hemos
trabajado con varios pero hay uno que la
hizo digamos hizo el modelo completo y
ahí éste sacó una ordenanza a través del
cual reconocida las niñas y niños por
sus aportes al menores 18 años de edad
por su aporte al desarrollo sostenible
de todo su distrito una cocineta con no
hay ni un solo indicador de desarrollo
que valore el aporte de las personas
menores de 15 años y bueno les dio hizo
esta ordenanza y reconoció las destiny's
que estaban siendo hechas en hogares y
en escuelas
en comunidades y lo reconoció en un gran
evento a todas las niñas y niños por su
aporte al bienestar de su pueblo la
metodología se ha multiplicado en más de
10 países la unesco lo reconoce como una
buena práctica de educación para el
desarrollo sostenible
en el año 2015 el ministerio de
educación del perú lo institucionaliza e
institucionales a la metodología con el
nombre de eso y espacios de vida y hoy
día está en más de 5.900 instituciones
educativas y aquí en ecuador el
ministerio educación hacia lo propio le
pone team y para el buen vivir y hoy
hasta en más de 10 mil instituciones
educativas todo con el concepto de que
la madre tierra esté presente como
profesora para nosotros es la maestra
que falta que la sociedad necesita más
empatía y compasión y necesitamos que
ella se presente en todos los sectores
donde están creciendo las niñas y niños
y bueno de ahí aníkin siguieron su
propio camino y ellos como la
presentación dijeron están en discovery
kids
estuvieron hicimos con una empresa
hicimos micro episodios años animados y
este
lo pusieron al aire en 20 países en a
toda américa latina y era telonera de
papi pero ahora ya no parece como ha ido
como le ha ido bien este ahora nos han
dicho que ha ido bastante bien que vamos
a trabajar para que tenga su propio
programa y a través del mismo programa
ella promueve las tierras de niños en
todos lados no y es en la meta nuestra
visión es que aníkin sean portavoces de
los portavoces en los o desde los
objetivos el desarrollo sostenible en
toda américa latina para niños y tampoco
que no para el mundo pero hay un tema y
adicional que es que nosotros hemos
visto que la forma que fui criado con mi
hermano del jardín vemos cosas y que no
están pero ahí hay algo que está ahí que
es importante pero que no se ve y que es
éste el de ese 18 que nosotros le
llamamos el o de ese 18 es el que le va
a dar sostenibilidad a los otros 17 y va
nosotros le hemos puesto el nombre de
empatía activa por la vida que quiere
decir que no solamente sientas por las
demás personas sino también por la
naturaleza y que no lo dejes en el hacer
sin que sino que pero no lo dejes en el
sentir sino que lo lleves al hacer
entonces por qué porque hemos visto que
la mejor manera es que hemos visto que
como cumplir ese objetivo es que si
crecemos en contacto con la naturaleza
lo vamos a lograr ese o de ese 18 porque
los que crecemos en contacto con la
naturaleza
la queremos la buscamos cuidar y la
buscamos replicar en nuestras vidas
cuando mi hija estaba por nacer no podía
comprar una casa con jardín porque era
muy caro pero con pregunté chito ahí o
se compre un departamento con techo y
miren como estaba ahí ahí y lo
transformamos en ese espacio un espacio
lleno de vida para que ella también lo
tuviera y cuando mi hijo estaba por
nacer mi mamá se emocionó se inspiró y
sacó cemento el cemento que había
cubierto mi jardín lo saco y ahí creamos
una tina que es esta donde están mi hijo
y mi hija ahora que lo disfruta el mismo
lugar
donde hace 45 años
mi hermano y yo estábamos siendo criados
por ese pedacito de la madre tierra
y ese mensaje el mensaje que les quiero
dar de parte de la madre tierra de esa
madre que me crió a mí de ese lugar que
fue tan importante en mi vida es que
para para luchar contra la apatía para
vencer la apatía la violencia y la
corrupción y avanzar hacia un mundo más
sostenible y afrontar el cambio
climático hay muchas cosas que podemos
hacer pero la única cosa que no podemos
dejar de hacer es criar a las niñas
niños en contacto regular y positivo con
la naturaleza porque porque ella tiene
la capacidad de crear un buen corazón en
ellos el tipo de corazón que necesitamos
para avanzar a un mundo más pacífico
sostenible ambientalmente sostenible
próspero y equitativo y esa es tarea de
todos nosotros mía de ustedes de
nuestros hogares escuelas comunidades de
nuestras empresas desde nuestros
gobiernos y
y tenemos que hacerlo y si lo hacemos
porque lo vamos a hacer va a florecer la
esperanza no solamente en la tierra sino
también en nuestros corazones muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]